okay let's get going for the last talk
of the day and we're talking with mr.
Floyd methods pleasure to have one of
your guys thanks Ben and hello everyone
so let's start with some admissions so
essentially I was thinking quite a lot
what to talk about and my first instinct
will of course to say what is the latest
and greatest and most advanced that I
can say about into different methods but
then I realize you know I look back to
you know what like how I struggled like
seven years ago or something when I try
to get into coaches optimization as a
Theory student and somehow the problem I
had there was that you know there's a
lot of sources to read about contoso
temptation you know some of the outer
surfaces are here except the problem I
had was that you know each of the source
develops a different perspective of an
only given building blocks but somehow
you know it's a little bit hard to draw
connections between these you know
different building blocks and also also
what I always like to have is I like to
have like a simplest working prototype
of a method before I try to Daniel
discover all the other beautiful ways of
thinking of think about the same objects
so specially so in the end what an
essence is a boot camp and you know I
hope you know I will be around and I
hope many of you will be around as well
and you know we can sort of continue
into the more advanced topic laters
later what I wanted to do here is I just
wanted to give the lecture that I wish
someone gave it to me seven years ago so
just to get you started so essentially
what I want to do is somehow I want to
introduce a bit of redundancy with like
what what Steve did so history I will do
the same thing as Steve did just
differently and somehow I will try to
give you like the self-contained proof
of like of the square root of M so this
is essentially was the best bound we
knew up to until a couple of years ago
for interpoma taught from basic
principles essentially starting from you
know just you have to know a little bit
of analysis like I think this will be
something that I seven-year at 7:07
years ago will be able to understand so
you know so hopefully this will be a you
know low enough bar that everyone will
be comfortable
okay good so let's get started
so essentially so this is all you know
let's start at the very beginning you
know reduce atomization is essentially
study of one simple problem namely
unconstrained minimization so imagine we
have some function f and let's assume
here that f is actually first of all
smooth okay and also let's say it's
actually strongly convex and I will
explain what strongly here means okay
and I hope we all know what convex means
and by the way this is a crash course so
I essentially will go on the critical
path to what I need and along the way I
will assume a way or we'll sort of
ignore a very important subfields of the
of the field in particular both these
assumptions are actually sort of
stronger assumptions and you know
there's a whole beautiful theory of how
to deal with this with the case when
this is not the case and you know there
are very interesting cases but you know
I will just focus on the what I need for
Interpol method okay so we hope to
minimize a function f over you know
unconstrained domain and we don't the
structure is smooth and strongly convex
which again I will explain what exactly
strongly means in a moment so how would
we go about this well canoe
systemization is a science of iterative
methods so what we would like to do we
would like to start with some solution
x0 and then somehow have a way of
refining it to a better increasingly
better solutions you know the step by
step
so in general we just wanted to find a
way of you know I have some social next
I and I would like to begin to have a
method of refining it to get some better
solution in an X I plus one okay and
that's essentially the basic you know
the basic scheme for most of the
community organization here okay now a
now we know the question is how do I do
that so how do i how do I perform this
very basic step if I want to minimize
such a function and this is already what
C for the set so instance there is only
one principle in continued optimization
and what it says something is that you
know no matter how complicated your
function f this as long as it's sort of
nice if you look close enough around the
point it's always actually a linear
function okay so essentially all that
you really need to know in conducive
transition is really tailored theorem
which tells you that here if I have some
point X around which I want to you know
I want to understand my function how it
behaves in the neighborhood when
essentially I can write so I have point
X and then there is the point that I
would like to understand who just like
some young X plus Delta so then I know
that I can write F F of Y as you know
the value of the function at the point X
this is the leg 0 of order term then
there is the first order term correction
ok then there is the second order term
correction here we have the Hessian of
Hessian of the function ok and then
there are many many many other terms and
I can just write these terms you know
for however long I want they will depend
on the higher orders of the function
okay so this is Taylor expansion tells
me that you know this really I can you
know I can understand the function the
value of the function everywhere by just
looking at this you know at this
expansion and somehow the interesting
terms that are you know the most
interesting here foreclose itemization
are does this to the first two because
you know this function let's call it f
hat of X of Y this is you know the
function is parameterize by our point X
and it of course varies over Y but the
nice thing about this function this is
just like the simplest possible function
it's just a linear function so sort of
like the crucial inside of you know of a
consulting dishes that let every
function once you look close enough and
I will explain why close enough in a
moment it just can be viewed as a linear
function and then over here I have some
kind of tail let's call it f tilde of of
of X which essentially a complex see
this is the error term this is the the
tail or the error of my approximation of
the function by this linear function
okay so somehow a clearly all these
terms here are at least quadratic in my
deviation so essentially as long as I I
am close the point Y is close enough to
X sort of this this approximation like
this error is small enough compared to
the you know to the approximation to get
so essentially if I look at the claw
enough neighborhood of my point you know
the function is essentially okay and you
know once I know that my function
essentially er is very easy to see you
know how to improve like how to locally
improve my my my guess all I do is
essentially I just think okay if I'm at
point X and this will be my point X I
now then what is known I just wanted to
reduce the value of this function the
most what is the direction that makes it
the most efficiently well essentially I
just need to this is my displacement I
just need this to be exactly in the
direction of this of this vector so say
this has told me that I should always
move in the direction of the main is the
minus gradient okay and that's exactly
the whole that's the whole principle big
like you know behind the most important
algorithmic on this elimination emigrate
descent okay and the algorithms very
simple now so we start with some X 0 and
then we just repeatedly refine our guess
for how level how many times we want by
just taking X I plus 1 being the old
point minus ETA times f of X i where ETA
is just some scale that just says that
how much do we move in a given direction
okay but this is the Albert and this is
the reason why the expert hit to work as
long as this ETA is small enough of
course now the question is what the ETA
should be and what should be the
convergence bound
okay and essentially you know clearly on
one hand you know we want it to be as
large as possible because you want to
make as much progress as we can on the
other hand you know we know that the
moment this data is large then somehow
this approximation becomes in exact and
somehow this tail this tail this tail
this tail error especially starts to
kick in so there is some and easy
compromise between these two things and
that what exactly will govern our choice
of eta okay so somehow what we need to
happen now to understand convergence
what we need to understand this actually
understand how does this tail behave as
a function of distance from our initial
point X okay and you know most common
way of doing this is essentially via
properties called smoothness and strong
convexity so essentially what you would
like to say you would like to say that
for every X okay and every Y what you
would like to do well here's our tail so
here is our our tail what he would like
well we would like on one hand to upper
bounded by the simplest possible
function that is like essentially not
linear minima quadratic so you would
like to put that this is at most some
beta over 2 times this displacement okay
and then we also would like to lower
bound this so we'd like to sandwich it
between these two quadratics okay so
essentially this parameter over here is
called al fide corresponds to strong
convexity and I will give you geometric
intuition in a second and this parameter
over here is refer the smoothness sort
of they are actually like in a
quantitative way of talking about
smoothness and strong convexity so
somehow pictorially what you want to say
I just want to say the following so
imagine we have our function f this is
our function f and now we look you know
at this function around some point
and some point X so what do we do well
we look first at this linear
approximation which will you be just the
and the line that is tangent to this to
this thing so this is this will be our
this would be our function f hat of X of
Y okay but now again we contents in this
error term and essentially what this
allows us to say that we can sandwich
the behavior of this function which you
know might become quite complicated
where we move far away by this two by
this to quadratic so one of them is this
you know to this lower bounding one okay
and the other one is the upper bounding
one sorry for my poor writing skill but
this is supposed to be a quadratic okay
sorry upper bound what looks like a
really tight you it's okay but like that
that won't work what will not work has
to be super sharp the upper bound is it
works at this here right so you know
it's these practitioners they actually
know how quadratics work yes so anyway I
hope you got the picture and my poor
skills at writing quadratics you know
it's one of my many poor skiers so
please forgive that okay but this is the
princess this is the idea and the moment
we now understand the behavior of this
complicated tale in terms of this lower
bounding simple function the quadratic
the lower bounding quadratic and the
rahbaniya quadratic we can actually
analyze you know the trade-off between
the progress made by this linear
approximation and their error introduced
by by you know by this tail essentially
as a function of like how much we move
and when you put over all of this
together and I will not do that but this
is actually quite simple what you can
prove is that if you want to get an
epsilon approximate solution okay all
you need is just number of iterations
number of gradient steps that is all of
a beta over alpha times log 1 over
Epsilon okay which is by the way the
dependence on a epsilon is very good and
you know somehow the crucial thing over
here is exactly this ratio of beta over
alpha which is usually called the
condition number
okay and somehow it tells us exactly you
know how well we are able to sandwich
this there okay so when it is good we
are converging fast if it's not so good
we are not converging so fast and by the
way again here I assume that alpha is
positive this exactly corresponds to
this strongly art here but in general if
we if alpha is zero then there is also
another bound that one can prove which
is much weaker but still works by the
way here is the distance of the initial
point from optimum and here you just
have good so essentially so this is
roughly you know this is like a Epsilon
right yes it's good to have some experts
in this in the audience okay so
essentially essentially so this is you
know this is the basics of gradient
descent and somehow this is the
principle and there is some math to get
here but actually this is very simple
once you once you have everything in
everything in place but now the question
is okay you know ya expect alpha to be
in this panel because we're like lower
bounding vieira yes so this is something
I wanted to sort of to skip but the idea
is that you need alpha because
essentially can I take it off line a so
special like I just will would this
allows you to say this allows you to
relate you know how far the optimal
solution can be so the problem is that
if you don't have this lower bounding a
quadratics then somehow you can't feel
how far the optimum is and I really
don't want to go into with that I'm
really happy to talk after this is
exactly this is a crash course so I am
skipping over anything that is not
critical for the further thing but I'm
happy to go gu going to top line okay
but the problem is that like you really
need it to be able to essentially get
this logarithmic dependence on error as
opposed to Paulina know so see here you
don't have depends on that on alpha and
I can explain why this makes sense
of line okay sorry about that the error
is measured in the value space yeah so
again for a logarithmic for algorithmic
regime which is something we'd focus
here more it doesn't really matter and
for another it because it does matter a
lot about you that's not good okay so we
know that it's a particularly in the
strongly convex case you know if we have
good condition number things are good
but what if we don't have good condition
number well so one thing that you can do
you can slightly improve this running
time and you can actually get by a via a
bit different scheme called accelerated
in the sense you can actually get a
square root of condition number here
that's one thing you can do but there is
also a more more interesting way of
trying to fight the cases when this
condition number is bad and what you
essentially do you essentially try to
use a different geometry than just l2 to
approximate your tale so surgery so so
far and by the way Africa's to write it
so far we try to understand this lower
and upper bounds in just the l2 norm so
in the Euclidean norm but actually this
makes perfect sense if we just take some
like put some arbitrary down here okay
in principle okay so as long as we allow
alpha to be 0 this makes definitely
perfect sense ok and now once use
different norm you might get a different
bounce on this because you know this
function might behave nicely in some
other nose this is often the case in
particular for max flow this is the case
and you know for many problems you can
choose the right know the like the for
max flow the L infinity norm is the
right norm to look at for for minimum
cost problem it's you know l1 norm is
right the right don't look at and you
know in this in the right norm this is a
kind of this this this you know this
value of beta actually can be much
smaller than what we would get if we get
if you if you work in the Euclidean in
the integration space okay there is just
one note that you know once we move from
you know from the Olivia norm into a
general norm then actually our gradient
state changes because now we don't
merely
move into the direction of gradient what
we actually have to do the most
efficient way
to move is in direction of I would call
it gradient harsh which is just defined
as the direction that maximizes the
following thing so this is just the
inner product I will explain in a second
what it is it may look scary but it's
actually very simple naturally what we
are looking is that you know we want to
choose the vector that you know
minimizes that pushes this term as much
as possible but somehow our currency is
the you know is the length of this
vector in the Y whatever norm we are
working with so if I put a pin under
here then the best direction is just to
go directly in the direction of the
gradient but if it's not an ingredient
norm and actually this might be some
some different direction that's left as
an exercise what it is for instance for
infinity norm or a one okay but you know
this is the only this is the only the
only modification you do it so
essentially you put in just you know
this over here you just put this hash
and then you have an algorithm that
works for a for a given norm where there
should be a square right because because
that's how we bound it here is because
essentially we're just saying you know
essentially we know that the extent of
the tale depends only on this on the
square of the of the know of the of the
norm of the displacement so that's my
stuff currency I wants to trade off you
know how much like I have towards how
much mileage I get out of the direction
the first thing doesn't have a square
yeah just this is the second one again
this is the progress we get from over
here and and the other thing is
penalizing us for whatever for whatever
tail where all right
what is the there is a square that part
is is busy a square because you notice
that here we have well like 1 1 vector
times the other vector so in the end is
proportional to the square so this is
something that depends on the square of
the length ok good
so that's great so that's you know that
sometimes gives you a mileage but
actually it turns out that you know for
some problems we can come up with the
right norm trans because you understand
the problem but also there is somehow
the generic there you know the best
possible choice of the norm that you can
imagine and essentially the the best
possible choice but if there is a caveat
here that you can imagine is too
is to consider so-called local norm
which again sounds scary but actually
isn't so a local norm of a vector is
essentially just what I do is I just
take the Hessian of my function at point
x so we depend on the point X I am
actually evaluating it it just I just
take the Hessian of of my function which
is if it's if it strongly convex it's a
it's a positive semi definite it's
supposed to defeat matrix so it gives a
it gives me a you know a scalar product
it gives it gives me a metric as well
and I just exactly look at the you know
at the length of this vector with
respect to refer to this metric okay why
this is a good norm to choose well the
well the idea here is that exactly the
square of this norm is exactly this
expression so in particular if I look at
now if I take V to be Y minus X then
exactly I can just just do some pattern
matching that you know what the term I
will get here will be exactly the first
term that I get in the Taylor expansion
so again as long as my you know as my a
well as my displaced is not too large
this term will you know will this term
will dominate the whole tale and you
know because of that I will actually get
a very good close to 1 ratio of beta 2
alpha trace will be alpha and beta will
be close to 1 or exactly one at the very
well but then they sort of degrade so
some of this is great because you know
once I use once I use this you know
local norm then I get like a very tight
you know upper and lower bounding on my
tail
but there are caveats but like we will
get back to it just for now just think
ok so if I use this norm what does the
gradient like what would be my gradient
step
well my gradient step after some quick
calculation in this case will be just
well will be just my original gradient
direction but then
I have two just multiplied by the
inverse of the Haitian I will get too
much so that the cake gets for now I'm
just saying you know at least when V is
small this is the best norm you can
consider your greenness and in de
because it's very nicely predicts the
tale and then you know your step then
will become essentially I can just
rewrite it your step would become
exactly this and this algorithm a you
know is very natural and it has its name
and its name is actually Newton's method
this is exactly what Steve talked about
and again this is a nice thing about
admission accommodation that every well
it's a nice thing and also very
perplexing thing that everything can be
derived in the motives of the way and
you might not realize this is the same
thing but essentially this is the
Newton's method algorithm that's
essentially does that now there is a
problem that already Elena pointed out
that somehow I am treating here because
you know well I would like to say now oh
well as I already waved my hand
you know for when I use this local norm
then this alpha and beta here are close
to one so I have close to one condition
number so I can just use this bound and
get like super fast convergence always
well this is actually not so because the
problem is that you know this is a local
norm meaning it actually can change from
you know from point to point and this n
is over here only works for fixed terms
so if I find the fixed norm that always
has such a good like tail bound
estimation I will be fine but here is
not so it's only like this good
estimation only works when V is not too
large okay and that's sort of a severe
limitation fitness method because now
you know it's actually very tricky to
analyze the converges so essentially if
it's if it happens that you know our
initial point is close to the well it's
sufficiently close to the optimal point
namely it's sufficiently close that our
you know local norm is at this starting
point is still good a predictor of the
of the local norm at this at this
optimal point and things will happen
very quick
very very nicely except if it doesn't
happen then it's not clear what in
general will happen so you can try to
analyze what will happen and it becomes
a bit nasty because what you have to do
then you essentially have to stuff like
bound the third order moments of the
Taylor expansion in order to know to
understand you know how bad your error
grows but yet this becomes messy okay
so that's so that's one so that's one
thing to remember that we chose method
you know as natural my head might be
it's actually quite nasty to analyze for
like global convergence okay so it's
it's not really possible well it is
possible but it's hard to get this kind
of bands for it however there is you
know there is a saving grace namely what
turns out is that actually nesterova
nemirovsky they actually identified a
broad class of functions for which you
can have a relatively clean analysis of
Newton's method and this class of
function is called self concordant
functions and i will not define what
they are because that's actually in a
sense not really important for this for
this talk but what is nice is that if
your function f is actually self
concordant which essentially involves
some condition that you know allows you
to bound the third order moments in
terms of the second order moments
appropriately then suddenly you can
actually get a global analysis of the
Newton's method and you know again I
will not cite what are the exact bounds
you get I will just need one important
fact namely what we have when our
function is self concordant is that
essentially you know there is a certain
important quantity that we just will
define which is called Newton decrement
okay and essentially it is just defined
as I take the gradient of my function
then I will write the expression I will
explain what it means
so essentially what it is really well
one way to look at it is you know it's
just I just take the I just take the
gradient like essentially I measure the
length of the gradient subject to the
norm that is given by the inverse of the
Hessian so here in local Norma had the
non inverse of the Hessian this is the
inverse of the Hessian and here you can
actually know that what it really is
that if you want to sound cool it is
actually the dual local norm do a local
norm of the of the action okay you can
also view it as a local norm of this of
this step so essentially this is the
local norm of the Newton step
okay and again there is like a couple of
other nice things they can say about
this but actually all I really need to
know that you get out of the analysis of
the Newton's method for second quadrant
functions and that's the only thing I
will black box that actually we needed
to get you know everything I want to get
is that there is the following fact if
you know I look at my content if this
square of this decrement is at most one
tenth okay then a Newton's method
converges very rapidly
okay and by very rapidly what they mean
by very rapidly I mean that it converges
in log of log of 1 over epsilon
interations so it's a block on the web
station is just like log of log or as
some books say it's at most 6 which is a
I guess a reasonable about yes I will
not I will not go on this especially
yeah but like this is actually like
essentially I will not be baited into
into this conversation
so essentially you know so this is
something especially we can assume that
the moment we get a solution X for which
you know for our first concordant
function this is at most one tenth we
know that we are done we essentially get
you know we get the optimal solution for
free because there are some constants
there and one thing works one fort will
also work it's small like it
sufficiently small constant and you can
actually depending on your definition of
self concordance you can yeah you can
get one because yes okay essentially if
you if you I am happy to talk about you
offline but essentially the think you
can prove is that your new your new
decrement which is also a measure of
error is you know at most I think what
you can prove is something like that so
essentially you square your all
decrement that's the boundary of your
new decrement so if this is smaller
sufficient smaller than one then you
will make progress but if it's larger
than one then actually you are diverging
so essentially this is only helpful but
this is sufficiently small yes so I got
confused because we were talking about
yes yes so and that's again one of these
things that I am allowed to do because
it's a crash course but they know what
I'm saying is so one thing is that if
you don't know except that the factor
cell phone coordinates if you just do
this with like ETA equal one you might
not be completely diverge the nice thing
that second course has gives you is that
actually you always will converge to
something but additional bones and as
they will be
only thing that we really care about is
that once you are sufficiently close we
have this very rapid convergence but
like New Zealand will convert always and
that's actually not you know that's not
typical yeah yeah there is that but it's
already cheating yes then you are
starting to there something to play some
tricks you don't need no know if you're
actually living you also you don't need
it I think you're still okay anyways the
point is it's good things happen I'm
pretty you don't need dumping fun we can
take it offline anyways in the end all I
need is just this fact actually that
like all I wanted to say up to now is
just to get this conclusion and now I
can just tell you I interpreted with
like essentially the best bond that were
known up to a couple of years ago okay
yes that's it that's that's a very
simple thing is just like you asked me
you have to guarantee that in the whole
region around the office once this is no
once you have this you actually that's
the whole point of safe concordant
special you know that the Oh new point
yes cell phone coordinates were very
important you know no that's okay allows
you to quantify what domain emergency is
everything is true again it's a crash
course I did exactly this kind of all
these tangents are beautiful I enjoy
them but I think if you here the first
time you just want to hear this
information
okay let me give the course the way I
want and
I agree but this is exactly like you
know you read these books and they are
beautiful but they go on to all these
things and by the time they are finished
with the tangent of Y you do here you
already lost you know the train of
thoughts okay I want what I promised
boy I promise you is this the shortest
path to the Interpol method that's what
I'm giving you and for that you don't
need to know why this is the case you
just need to accept this fact property
is independently for starting point the
property is a property of the function
and what is true is that once you have
the projects function which will be
decay it is the property SS and then you
know that it will hold two like this
essentially what you will have is
exactly this behavior that your new
point will like it will be smaller so I
think this is more than one this will
also be smaller than one okay and that's
the only thing you have to know about
new hospital they offend you greatly or
only a little bit no it fix it six come
on you are not reading Italy it's six
and that's not important no no way it's
Lauren would be fine
the point is that if you have this
condition you are done it's like you
have an optimum and social okay great so
that's really all I really need for you
to remember so far but I hope I wanted
to motivate this fact so it is you you
have some idea where it's coming from
now we can actually do something useful
and solve a linear program okay so
imagine that I want to solve a linear
program of the following form okay so
without loss of generality every linear
program can be cut like this this is
like a dual essentially form of the
linear program and I did the evil thing
and I changed notation that is diffused
and essentially you know I just like
there is some like renaming of the of
the of the vectors that would get you
back to his regime but no it's not
really that important there we go so you
can definitely believe that every LP can
be cast in this form okay and now the
question is you know how how would I go
about solving this about solving this
you know this this problem okay
so as already Steve mentioned somehow
the the first trick you want to do is
like actually dealing with inequalities
it's quite hard when you want to do it
explicitly so what we do we instead we
cheat and instead we try to get rid of
these inequalities by changing the
objective function so how incorporating
them into objective functions we're
optimizing so what we will consider
instead we'll consider the function f mu
that has of course the original cost
function we had but then divided by mu
you already have seen it in in stiff
stock okay and then we have this barrier
function which essentially what it has
it has one term for every inequality
here and it's you know it's a lot this
is the logarithmic it's the logarithmic
it's the logarithmic barrier so
essentially what it does it just looks
at you know at the Jade constraint and
it paralyzes if it's getting like if
this thing is getting close to being
invisible then essentially this shows
and somehow tries to rip my last from
there okay so essentially so as long as
I am you know start from some point that
is feasible and I try to optimize this
function I would be naturally repelled
from ever crossing into invisible region
okay so from now on essentially you know
what has happened is that essentially
what you can observe is that you know
okay that two observations so one
observation is that actually if mu is
large sufficiently large then I can
solve sorry let's increase the notation
before I I talked about observations so
let me define X mu star as the optimum
solution to this to this function f mu
okay so this is just our mean over X of
f mu X okay this is my concert musician
problem I can just define instead I just
define the optimum and of course it will
depend on me right because we have this
factor mu that trades of our cost
function would like to optimize versus
you know this barrier that is just
making sure that we are not getting any
infeasible point
okay now observation that we talk such
that you want to make is one is that
actually you can get X mu star for
sufficiently large mu so essentially if
mu is large enough magically and
actually Steve explained how you can how
we can do it you can actually get this
solution you know right away okay and
then the other thing that is actually
important for us is essentially if I
look at the limit of mu staying positive
but approaching zero of these solutions
then essentially this will become the
optimal solution to the original LP I
wanted to solve okay and the more
precise way of stating it what you can
show is that you know the cost of you
know your solution X star mu compared to
the best to the cost of the best
solution is at most mu times M okay when
M is the number of
is number of constraints okay so clearly
you know if I get mu sufficiently small
I can get arbitrarily close to the well
to the GU solution okay so that's great
so now all I need to do I need just to
minimize this function for sufficiently
small mu and began with it right and I
already have metals for doing it so you
know one way to try to do it just like
let's apply grading the same to it and
see what happens and you know it will
work except the problem is that you know
if I look at this function is actually
its strong convex in like in any
reasonable setting but the value of
alpha the condition number may be
essentially arbitrary bad so you know we
would solve a problem but it would take
a long time so that's not satisfactory
somehow we would like to have a bound
that do not depend on this kind of thing
on this on the on this you know on this
you know how good alpha and beta is so
what do we do well we would like to use
Newton's method instead okay we would
like to essentially use gradient descent
on this function but in this local norm
given by this function okay but now the
problem is that as I said noodles means
actually is not a great method for
minimizing the function if we just find
stuff from an arbitrary point what we
need we actually need a good point to
start from to have a hope that we
actually converge quickly okay and that
exactly is this kind of you know like
that's where the no idea of safe
integral method is also a central path
following interpreters comes in so what
I will do well I will not try so you
know the one thing you could try is just
now I just get some starting solution
for MU being large and in one shot you
know I said Moo to be small enough for
me and just use Newton's method to
converge directly to this thing that
will not work internal because again
this solution
you know the initials if I get might be
very far from the solution that I want
to get so what I do instead is actually
and said I just try to you know slowly
like slowly convert let's slowly chase
the point I want to do so a little bit
of algorithmic intuitions and again a
stiff already essentially drop the drew
this picture but let me let me draw it
again so essentially
if this will be our in oh the feasible
region you know defined by our
inequalities okay and let's say over
here our cost our cost vector is over
here so our solution is somewhere here
what really happens is that you know if
I take mu to be large or let's say you
know infinity or close to infinity then
this optimal point x star mu will be
something called analytic center of this
Polito okay something in the middle that
tries to stay away from all the
constraints as much as possible okay but
now you know essentially as I make new
smaller and smaller what will happen is
like I can look at the solutions that I
get I will get a curve in this feasible
space that is slowly approaching this
optimal solution essentially as I'm
turning off the barrier like more and
more I'm getting closer and closer to
what in the minimizing of the cost
function is getting me through and
essentially all I want to do here is
instead of you know the first idea would
be just start here and try to converge
directly to this point over here that
will not work so what I do instead is I
just like I just have a moving target so
see what I do I start with the initial
point then I find some you know I don't
try to get all the way here directly I
try to get here to some point X star mu
prime for some mu prime that is you know
1 minus Delta times mu so this is just
something that this is just slightly
smaller mu but not too drastically
smaller okay and I hope that this you
know Delta will be small enough on one
hand it should be large because you want
to make progress but other hand this
will be small enough that actually this
new point X mu prime star will be close
enough to X mu star so I actually get
the rapid convergence like so
essentially that this solution is
avoiding the rapid convergence radius of
the of the you know of the Newton's
method okay that's that's the whole
scheme so sort of I would like to
essentially have like I try to you know
to follow this curve by just the design
of discrete steps using using Euler's
method and that's exactly the whole
scheme I want to do clearly this will
work the only question is
how a large Delta can I put here for it
to to make it work because there is
always sufficiently small Delta for
which this will work because you know
for Delta equals zero this is the same
solution so clearly we have rapid
convergence and there has to be some
positive Delta for which is still will
be within the radius of very rapid
convergence the questions can lower
about how big the Delta is so as we
always a guaranteed that will be close
enough okay
that's the only thing that is left
essentially once we said that if you
have some lower bound on Delta then we
know that our number of our total a
total number of iterations will be no
Delta inverse times log 1 over Epsilon
ok so essentially we'll get an epsilon
Epsilon optimal solution after there
will be MSHA after this many iterations
if we have some absolute lower bound on
on that yes do you expect
not by it instead of thank that's that's
a good question you as we see we will be
able to do it like the true we are able
to get this multiplicative decrease in a
principle this is like without loss of
generality because you know there is
definitely some positive Delta fruit
this would be true but it turns out that
actually you can get a multiplicative
decrease like that so this is not
obvious why this should be but this is
what you want if you want to have the
kind of logarithmic independence an
error and as we will see actually you
can get that so sorry
well essentially I want mu to be a Cylon
over m right so essentially I get that
this is at most Epsilon so this would be
just the error in the value of the
interval you of the yes but again it's a
crash course I don't mention this world
like a lie I'm just telling you what I
hope you need to know to just get the
shortest working proof of it and it's
and then we have the rest of the
semester
to discover all these beautiful
connections and the beautiful views on
that I don't know maybe I am a bit going
against your taste is by doing this but
that's how I learn and just wanted maybe
some of you are similar to me so that's
how I do it if you are disgusted by my
ignorance and barbaric a presentation
I'm sorry this is a record that right ok
good ok and so it is everything
yes that's all true but I just don't
want to go into but that's a very good
intuition but here in the end we don't
need to know like so think you can write
it like that and then magically as we
will see in a moment we will get we will
get this bound you know you can again
you can figure out why you expect it to
happen I just was prefer to do the you
know the show not tell or whatever
whatever is the the meaning of this I
just prefer to have a proof and then see
and only then in retrospect see where
did it come from
okay so let me and so essentially so
what do I need to just analyze I just
need to analyze the following well the
following situation so imagine you know
I have a solution the optimal solution
to my problem for some value of MU and I
want to understand you know how big can
tell like a can Delta be while still
guaranteeing that this you know the
optimum solution to the new problem for
the new mio prime is still close enough
to the to my to my to this solution so I
get a rapid convergence with users well
right this is all I need to do but now I
exactly know what is the math I need to
do to compute that because what does it
mean so okay so by the way logarithmic
barrier is self concordance like for
this is very important so that's the
whole that's I guess part of the whole
reason why we we put it there in the
first place but so now I can just
essentially apply this fact to it am I
saying something wrong it is actually I
didn't define of course that that's a
good point
yeah but that's all you have to show
like essentially you have to believe me
that the lager fraction is self
concordant according to the right
definition that makes this table intro
good you know so for now there's there
is nothing to like that now I have to
analyze this this Newton decrement and
see if it's like how big Delta can be
whilst it says so still satisfy this
that's the whole question it's
essentially what I need to do now
yes so essentially okay so what I need
to do and this is like very simple now
Dre the all the a bit more technical you
know heavy lifting is in this in this
fact and what I need to look at I need
to look at my Newton decrement with
respect to MU prime because I'm
minimizing the function f mu Prime and
my initial point that is X a mu star
okay and I would like to see well I will
ideally well look at the square of it
and I would like to show that this is at
most 110 for some value of Delta okay so
what I just want to look at this
quantity what is this quantity
well we know from definition that this
is exactly the gradient of MU prime at
the point X mu star the hessian view
prime at the point mu star inverse and
again the gradient okay that's exactly
the that's exactly the that's exactly
the you know the quantity you want to
bound so let's look at it for a moment
what it is exactly
well this is actually just an exercise
in taking taking derivatives so I will
so I will spare you so so let's just
think so what is yes here is lambda and
oh sorry yeah so essentially okay so
first of all what is the gradient of f
of U for a given you and given X well
after little bit of computation you will
know that this is C over mu so this is
just the no this is the first time that
you get minus essentially a transpose
times s and I will explain as in a
moment times all ones vector so what is
s where essentially for every for every
for every for every inequality I defined
the slack so what does the slack is
essentially this is AJ transpose times X
minus BJ so essentially this says know
how far I am from violating given
equality so I have such a number for
every inequality and now essentially the
the matrix s is just the diagonal matrix
where you know each entry it's an M by n
matrix where each diagonal entry desc it
just corresponds to the exactly the
value of the slack okay and then I take
an inverse of the situate this is this
is the inverse okay so this is this is
the gradient and there is a nice way of
writing this essentially as a hat
transpose where I just like have a
shortcut a hat is just the s minus 1
times de okay just because this
expression will show up a lot so I just
want to shortcut it okay that's the
gradient now what is the what is the
Hessian the Hessian well this is a
constant term so it says really goes
away and you what you get out of the
Hessian is that essentially this is a
hard transpose times a hat so that's
what you get when you compute what is
the Hessian so essentially you can see
that the Hessian is essentially sum of
rank one matrices where you know each
waiting case with s is just 1 over the
slack squared times the corresponding
Rank 1 matrix corresponding to the
corresponding to the to the row
okay so particular this shows us that
indeed this function is positive
semi-definite as long as this thing's
span you know okay this is the this is
full rank but here okay I'm suppressing
that because the the notation will be
very unwieldy yes that's very important
s is a function of X so in particular
that's why I hear you have hidden s - -
- because actually I have to
differentiate it as well okay
so far so good so yeah so essentially
like the way the Hessian depends on X is
exactly via the slacks which changed
because no the the matrix a is the same
the only thing that changes is there is
our dyslexic okay I'll just weightings
over here okay good so now we now we can
essentially evaluate our you know our
thing so so first of all I want to
evaluate what F like the gradient of a
new prime at the entry point X mu star
is well what is it again I can just use
the definition
so you know mu prime is 1 minus Delta
times mu and then the rest of this is
the same and again this a that like
essentially this end this a is given by
by this solution okay what is that the
only thing changes is essentially
essentially this ok now I will just
treat a bit because you know I just
don't want to deal with the exact math
so the way I can I can write it I can
just write it as a you know as C like
Delta times C right a plus the gradient
of F nu add the MU at the point x vo
star okay because essentially you know
if I had seen you over here that would
be exactly the gradient of the function
f nu at this point and then I get you
know have what one was that especially
this gives me a turbot is roughly
behaving like over mu yes of course
thank you okay but now the question is
what is that
zero right because we know that we are
minimizing the function f mu and we are
at the optimal point so clearly there's
no way of improving it so this is always
zero okay now so essentially we get here
that this is roughly Delta C over mu and
actually there is something more that we
can say about this essentially since we
know that you know this gradient is zero
it also means if I look at the
definition that C over mu is equal to a
hat transpose times all one vector right
this is just what it means for this for
this for the green to be zero okay so
essentially what it means is that this
gradient that that I have here is
exactly Delta a hard transpose times one
okay almost done so I can write now that
the thing I want to estimate is
essentially I will just pull Delta
squared in front of it and now I just
have sorry I have a hat transpose all
one vector transpose times a a hat
transpose a hat minus 1 a hot transpose
all one okay that's what I want to
evaluate me this is very cool cool
interpretation but I will not go into it
sorry about that I just won't understand
you know how large can this be okay
because once I know how large it can be
since I in the end wants to have this to
be at most one over 10 it will tell me
you know how small Delta has to be for
the condition to happen right so that's
the only thing is to bound this thing
now if you know a little bit of algebra
you know one trick to evaluate this kind
of stuff so essentially one nice way of
doing it is if I have a if I want to
evaluate how much
such a such a quick like how much like
like you know how big is you know in
such equation is all I have to do is
essentially this is exactly didn't I can
write it as an optimization problem okay
so this is I know it's penetrator but
like let me you know I may not be very
well versed in consume addition but I
know that much but that's not the point
it's no a hat a hat is from you yes a
hat is from you now now we got rid of
new prime there's no menu prime anymore
you know but the question depends like
it doesn't depend at all at mu mu it
only depends on the point and the point
is X mu star yes so the only thing that
changes for it depends on mu prime is
the gradient and then there is mu prime
here but the matrix a depends on the
point that you are at not at the value
of MU okay so they are all the same I'm
not cheating here they're all the same
the same matrices and essentially I can
write it as just the minimum over all
the vectors of essentially the you know
the norm of the vector subject to the
constraint that be sorry see there is
such that B times Z is equal to V okay
so essentially I can view it as an
optimization problem when I want to like
optimize over Z it's just like five four
minutes you will survive I hope this
heresy essentially is so you know so
this is this is the variable Z and
essentially the optimal solution to this
problem is given by what we exactly want
just so I don't get
[Music]
just by B transpose B transpose oh it D
be transposed to B minus 1 B is that
correct no it spit out without ending ok
that's the solution that you get and
then you will get exactly this but
somehow the point here is that this is a
mini mediation and this is optimal
solution but you know if I choose any Z
here I will get an upper bound on this
quantity right this will gives me the
best upper bound but any upper bound
will work as long as i satisfy this week
especially now let's apply it apply this
thing - you know - well - to our problem
so we have like Delta squared and now
essentially I can upper bounded by Z
like the norm of Z for any Z such that
what has to happen
well a translate a hat transpose Z has
to be equal to the a hat transpose all
one vector okay I just stated it so any
Z that satisfies this its norm will be
upper bound on this quantity but now
there is a very easy upper bound it's
just a pattern matching I just take Z to
be all ones vector really this will be
equal and norm of this will be at most
Delta square times M okay
and that's always will be true so now
what it tells me is that as long as
Delta is at most 1 over square root of
10 over m okay actually this property
will be satisfied so I will converge
okay that's it we are done okay this
just tells us that essentially setting
Delta to this quantity will make the
whole will make the whole the whole will
make the whole scheme converge and the
you know the the final bound you will
get is essentially all tilde of square
root of M loved one over himself which
is by the way there you know the result
of Reiniger don't remember the year that
was it
you you now know how to solve linear
programs in the century this was and
instead still is the best time we know
so let me take this minus five minute
you are Steve told us that no way okay
so it's not the more technical part what
you do one way to do it is just brute
force essentially what you do you
essentially brute force your your LP by
just setting it up in such a way that it
has you know you can get just the
solution for X mu and just right now you
just add some a penalty for it whatever
like you just add new variables and you
penalize them so in the optimal through
they are equal to zero and you know you
set up things that you get the
optimality conditions for this thing for
some value of mu in main for instruction
natural way to do it yes so that's one
point that I'm sorry okay good so so
anyway so yeah so this I didn't tell you
exactly how to initialize that's true
but I tell you I tell you that this is
not the difficult part and I didn't tell
you the analysis of Newton's method for
certain functions but model of these two
things you know everything now that
there is to know about about getting the
integral method so let me just say two
things about what lies beyond it and
Erin will talk more about it tomorrow so
now we know we got this bound and the
question is you know if you remember
Steve said that in practice the students
methods seem to at least the writing
position of each method seems to take
not more than 50 iterations here we have
square root of M
clearly there is some slack and I think
the overwhelming believe is that you
know the square root of M is not the
right bound so how could we go around
trying to you know to get something
better than square root of n okay so
essentially what has to happen is well
one way to maybe that's something that
you know Aaron and myself and others are
currently exploring is essentially to to
sort of Torah examine this fact okay and
figure out so clearly this condition is
sufficient for fast convergence of
Newton's method so if you have a
satisfied everything is great this
condition essentially corresponds to
like this this you know decrement
squared is exactly you know it's exactly
the l2 norm squared of this optimal
solution okay so that's essentially what
the saying that if this l2 norm of this
optimal solution to do this projection
that we are competing here if it's you
know a essentially if it's at most one
over tenth I know I can you know I I
will have rapid convergence however if
you look more closely into the proof you
realize that actually increases it you
can put l4 norm here and the proof still
will will work true okay so essentially
what you can show is that like just
having L for non being at most this will
be sufficient
that's actually fundamental because of
course we know that the l2 norm is
always or the other way round is upper
bounding the l4 norm but now you know so
what might happen is that l2 norm is
large but l4 norm is small and you can
still have rapid convergence so say sure
this is a sufficient condition but
turning to 31 and of course in the worst
case these two norms are equal or close
to equal and this corresponds to the
cases when you know one of the
components in this projection is very
large but this is only the worst case
and you know maybe it is that this worse
case doesn't happen unfortunately it
does happen but what you can show that
is that maybe there is a way of
massaging your problem so this bad
things do not happen too often in
particular the crank that you end up
trying to pull is essentially here you
know here
we just essentially weighted each of
these logarithmic terms the same in the
same way too we just have a weight of
one here what you can do instead is you
can put some weights here and somehow
weight different you know we want to
waste different terms differently and
this actually makes sense because
imagine that I just take my you know my
linear program and now I just like
multiply we take one constraint and put
it ten times into my LP from the point
of view of this method it's actually we
suddenly both this particular inequality
more when it shouldn't because doesn't
change the geometry of the problem so it
says so what it hinted is actually there
is no maybe a better waiting of this
barrier that that leads to a better
behavior in the context of you know of
this condition so that we don't exactly
know how to show that there is a 1
waiting that actually gives you a better
like better behavior in this L for norm
what we can show is that there is a way
of manipulating this weight as you go to
ensure that you offer enough you have
this L for this L for condition
satisfied even though L 2 condition is
not satisfied okay and essentially there
are two types of results that emerge one
from from them so one of the one of the
type of result is essentially shows that
when you apply this thing so what you
can do you can take an interpreted and
you can solve the corresponding a LP in
M to the 1/3 log 1 over epsilon
iterations except as you go there as you
to achieve that as I said you need to
change this weight and this actually
when you want to do with just brute
force you need to perturb your cost
vector so in the end you can solve any
LP fast except this is the app you solve
is not the LP you started with so this
is of limited limited use still it
turned out that for certain specific
problem and most notably a max flow and
maybe shortest path with negative
lengths negative length arcs you know
there is some way in which you can
control exactly how you perturb this
cost vector and you know what is the
impact of this and what you will get out
of that
is the running time when you know
actually each station will just work in
linear time a number of iterations will
be not exactly into the one turret it
will be something slightly worse it will
be always something 3/7 right I should
know that right log 1 over epsilon so
you have m to the 3/7 number of
durations and this is for actually unit
capacity so that's important unit
capacity capacity max flow and this is a
result of me for max flow and there is a
simpler version more recently and then
there's that for photos puff is the
result of a coin myself some cuffs key
and Vlada be recent and all of them are
the semester and two of them are
actually in this room so you can ask
them about so that's one kind of results
you can get out of this the other one
also very exciting is the result by a
lien seat first
so Aaron will talk he is here and he
will also talk probably a bit about this
in the in the tomorrow essentially what
they say is as the following so you know
so here we managed to improve the power
from 1/2 to something better than 1/2 or
improve I would say but now there's also
another thing that like sort of from the
theory of self comfort and function we
know that there are always barriers
whose complexity will not be square root
of M as we proved here but actually
square root of n where n is the
dimension of the problem and usually M
is much larger than n ok and he'll a
nemirovsky and instead of showed a
barrier that leads to such a complexity
except the barrier is not really
computable like there is you know we
don't get an efficient algorithm it but
then in early and seat fourth you know
used very beautifully use this idea of
changing paths and sort of this insights
and he will talk about this more later
to actually make sort of this bound
algorithmic innocence or actually very
efficient and they indeed can solve any
NLP in close to square root of n bounds
and there is no cave at like here that
you have to particularly they just solve
it you know honestly and without
problems
essentially in this in this I move about
and again the ID debate the the point of
stuff is exactly playing with this
playing with this with this weights and
finding the right relating the factually
that makes geometric sense and are we
talking more about this so you know so
sorry for going over time I'm happy to
talk about anything I said tune is crash
course and now X you know explain and
sort of like expand I'm happy to talk
about you know some of this following up
Roark I'm around the whole semester
please feel free to approach me thanks
[Applause]
I'm around you can ask questions on that
after so so do we know that at least for
some structured problems that
self-importance is really necessary or
do you think there is a possibility of I
am recorded here so I will not tell you
what I think but let's just say I think
self-confidence fury is a very beautiful
theory I think it definitely is not like
like I think you have to go but like it
is possible and and you know you should
go beyond the fury of self-confidence to
get better bands in particular in a
sense one of the results in the Lisa's
first paper actually shows that you can
now take a poet OPFOR with self
concordance like probably you know we
would would require square root of M
iterations and they still can get square
root of n by designing more you know
more specialized barrier function and
sort of are more efficient yes so so
again so second bonus is a very nice
abstraction in particular it allowed me
to black box a lot of nasty like
calculations here so when it works is
great I definitely don't think that we
should look at traffic or dance anymore
I think now we have to go beyond self
concordance to you know to get some
better bounds
one of the things of importance it's not
all that easy
i I think Aaron will totally be able I
don't think that is really experts
because in says you can talk about
John's ellipsoid like all these things
here so I don't think we really
understand how much of it translates
some of the truth translate we don't
know I think I don't know more than me
about that but that's a great question
that's something to expert on this
semester exactly what does it you know
and this is the beak you know the big
kind of deem of this thing is that like
at first we had this insights to improve
finding time of LPS and to know improve
max for any time and something but in
the end who learn something about the
geometry and about this you know all
this math behind this that hopefully we
can export back into the fury so that I
think that's a great you know thing to
explore at later in the semester
[Applause]